Parliament will debate draft laws on  energy efficiency and renewables aiming  in a reduction of 40% of EU energy  consumption by 2030 since last December  a wave of protest is shaking Iran  resulting in numerous death the  Parliament assesses the situation MEP s  review Estonia's six-month EU council  presidency Bulgaria took over on the 1st  of January and will set out its  priorities  liova red car the Irish Prime Minister  will share his vision on the future of  Europe this initiates a series of  debates between EU leaders and MEP s  European cyber surveillance tools were  used by authoritarian regimes during the  Arab Spring members of parliament want  stricter export controls